we're going into live
streaming right welcome everybody to
November 7th
infrastructure
meeting um we have no apologies
and uh Declaration of interests um
anyone uh the chair has one which is to
do with tab five
the uh Southland Center parade um so
I'll be stepping down I'm cheering that
one uh no one else okay that moves on no
public forum takes us to the minutes of
the infrastructure meeting on Tuesday
10th of October can I have someone moved
there correct thank you bar seconded
Grant put that all in favor I that takes
us on to the road closure for the Santa
parade so uh
Tom yeah come I'm just going to sit
there the
gallery so they see everybody gets five
Minutes of Fame I'm probably only going
to get two I would think with this paper
proportionately that could be quite
substantial on this
m least St Doug are you going to speak
to this paper you don't Doug
no sure uh my name's Doug Rogers I'm
very new here so bear with
me so Doug you obviously take the paper
is red um I mean just bring out anything
that you you feel as though you may want
raise but assume that we've read the
paper um you might just comment on the
change of Route this
time I could do I didn't know the route
had
changed you want to comment on it I I
could add a little bit in there that I
know that our local our internal team
have worked with the organizers um and
given that the the um the access to
inago Central comes off T Street they've
um Revisited the route and The Roots now
from Gara Street down D Street and it
loops around the Troopers Memorial and
comes back down the other side of D
Street to G Street again so I guess it's
just trying to find a compromise that
historically it used to go D Street T
Street Deon Street um but I guess the
that would in in effect cut off the
access to the car park so that's just a
compromise they've come up with and
they're going to tral that this year to
see how it works than R douer are there
any other comments you want to make on
the paper I just take it as rude okay
then any questions to Doug no question
just happy to move the three
recommendations okay seconded by Leslie
um are there any other comments or
anybody wants to make or questions okay
if not Ben all in favor say I I I anyone
opposed okay carried thank
you sorry 45 seconds of
Fame
30% of the
meeting right not finished yet that
takes us on to the bluff Center
parade um again Russell is or Doug do
you want to comment on anything
relevant take this read Mr chairman yeah
any changes nothing nothing good to know
happy to move we'll see moved Darren
seconded
Leslie uh the three recommendations
there put those all those in favor I
against that is carried and now we go to
The Bert Monroe and the closures
necessary there
Russell this is this is a timing issue
between Doug and I when Doug's taking
all this paper was written a little bit
earli I guess that's why it's under from
me the this race obviously just needs to
make sure we just got a good safety plan
in place because obviously there were
some issues with the um B Monroe and
there just a little bit more care that
we're and we are liasing with the
organizers directly so that's really a
guess the steps that we've now got in
place since last year for all of our
road closures so this is one we'll just
have a bit more of a watchful eye um you
might notice that
where it normally would have closed
Arena Avenue in those places that's been
that area has been not being used this
this year so it's slight changed and I
guess that's the organizers um
determining it was more
um I guess the organization of that area
was more difficult to arrange
so no that's true and they are traveling
slightly quicker than the Magic Dragon
flight yeah so slightly
slightly so uh any questions for Russell
on that otherwise three recommendations
kind have someone move uh move Trish
seconded Peter put that motion all those
in favor I against that is carried now
that brings us to public excluded
session um and the reason being is that
we've got to receive some minutes so
Jill
you